this mom entered a tournament and made
it to the semi-finals by accident
Twitter user Zane tweeted that his mom
had accidentally entered an official
Candy Crush tourney and had no idea what
it was the tournament in question is
Candy Crush All-Stars which will have a
live Final in London next month for the
top 10. Kotaku Jong spoke to the
48 year old mom in question Aaron Roden
who said that she accidentally clicked
yes when trying to decline participating
in events unfortunately Mrs Rhoden will
not be going to London to compete with
the best of the best as she was knocked
out in the semis Rhoden told Kotaku that
she had watched videos to get better at
the game and that Zane did her chores
for her that weekend so she could
compete which mirrored when she would
have to drive Zane to out-of-state smash
tournaments how is that for your daily
dose of Serotonin